[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast long one for you today but if
you're interested at all in the nature
of reality think you'll stay tuned today
the guest is Dr Robert Gilbert he has a
PHD in international studies he was also
a U.S Marine Corps instructor in the
field of nuclear biological and chemical
warfare defense I think that just means
smart
and that's what you'll experience today
in the interview he educates in the
fields of spiritual science biological
science biogeometry which is he is the
first person that has been able to teach
biogeometry outside of Egypt he also
studies and shares on the rosicrucian
order point is I didn't really know
where to start because he's so smart and
there's so much information that he is
so so studied in and so so intellectual
about but he is so articulate and so
those spaces that we got into the most
today were spiritual science and
biological science and just how the Body
Works chakras energy how we can move it
what is disease how to move the energy
body how we're interacting with the
world around us people it was honestly
just fascinating it's densely packed
with Vital Information to live your best
life I mean at the end of the day that's
what it's about like what are we here
for how do we make the most amount of
progress in this life so that we can
progress through and we don't have to
come back and do it again because that's
essentially what happens if you want to
know any more information about Robert
you go to his website at vesca.org if
you want to watch videos you can go to
Gaia TV he has an entire series there so
enjoy this deep dive into the world of
patterns and geometry and how that
interacts with our life please hit
subscribe let me know what you think in
the comments and see you next time
element is a tasty electrolyte drink
with everything you need and nothing you
don't that means that there's lots of
salt and no sugar element is formulated
to help anyone with their electrolyte
needs and is perfectly suited to any
diet or lifestyle for me I drink element
all day every day I put it in just about
every single drop of water that I drink
for me it feels like it helps keep me
full it helps give me more energy and I
feel like water is absorbed better by
the body when it has element in it it
truly feels like magic to me receive a
free element sample pack with any order
when you use drinkelement.com pretty
intense that's drinkelement.com pretty
intense that's an interesting backdrop
you've got there it's very very colorful
what is that it's a tapestry from
Zimbabwe that a friend of mine brought
back from there when I was in college
and International Studies very very cool
I love that that's beautiful yeah thank
you I'm very into color and shape so
well I wasn't sure if it had some
geometry uh nature to it that calibrated
energy this isn't a joke I'm deadly
serious like love that stuff and that's
mostly what I want to talk to you about
you know biogeometry I'm fascinated by
I'm fascinated by energy my biggest
question in life is what is this reality
we're living in like what is the truth
about this reality because well I feel
it's a big question and I'm not 100 sure
we can get down to it although I bet
with this conversation you could
probably enlighten me and tell me what
the answer is or at least that would be
fun
um but when we know more about the
nature of our reality we know how to we
know how to play the game yes we know
how to how to maximize it we know we we
are then not only also hoping or even
trying to believe something we know it
and when we know it and we embody it
completely then it's a real real reality
there's no contradiction contradicting
energy from sort of believing which
implies that you don't and you need to
effort for it so let's I would love to
get to the point where we can all
understand and embody the truth about
this reality so I think we start with
biogeometry uh just a little bit of of
background to that I had been an
instructor in the Marine Corps in the
nuclear biological chemical defense
field
and at that time I began to study
aspects of biology chemistry physics
that
are
the background to all physical reality
and I got fascinated by how what we know
about these systems that create
everything in our world actually goes
back to ancient knowledge from the great
temples in the ancient world the great
systems of spiritual initiation and so
when you begin to study the foundations
of modern Atomic science you come back
to the platonic solids that were taught
by the Greeks thousands of years ago and
even the first nuclear weapon was based
on one of the platonic solids that the
Greeks warned against thousands of years
ago so getting into this aspect of
looking at modern scientific research
and what we had discovered about the
patterns behind things
and then seeing that many of those
patterns were known in the ancient world
but they understood those patterns in a
much larger holistic spiritual context
then in the time that I was uh after the
Marine Corps got into field of
international studies I was able to
study systems all over the world and how
they understand the patterns of creation
to not only change our own lives but to
change the world around us
and that led me to the field of sacred
geometry and I was very fortunate to be
able to create a series on the Gaia
channel that came out last year on
sacred geometry to be able to introduce
people to some of the most important
Concepts in that field and I like to
approach it in such a way that it's
really the study of patterns sacred
geometry is the study of all the
patterns that exist because there's a
pattern to everything
and the key to empowerment is
understanding what the pattern is of
that thing whether it's our finances
whether it's our relationships whether
it's our health there's always a pattern
behind success or failure and in the
ancient world they understood that these
patterns also exist for understanding
who am I why am I here what is the
purpose of this current Incarnation what
is the purpose of us incarnating into a
physical body in a physical world to
begin with I was very fortunate to now
over 20 years ago meet Dr Ibraham Karim
from Cairo Egypt who's an absolutely
remarkable natural scientist and
professionally he's an architect
and he trained me in his field of
biogeometry which we'll talk about here
in just a moment and I was very
fortunate to be the first person outside
of Egypt that he invited to become an
instructor in the field because I came
to all of his trainings and I took
copious notes and I arranged it all in a
new format and I was very very engaged
with it and I have a natural resonance
with ancient Egypt and this type of
spiritual and vibrational knowledge it's
something that's very important to me as
a kid I never understood why people
focus their attention on such transient
things and didn't ask the most basic
question about who am I and why am I
here and how do we use this current
incarnation in the best way before it's
all over oh my god well that's literally
like what I like I obviously come up
with a lot of questions I do a lot of
research I already knew a ton of your
work I'd listen to it a bunch which is
what drove me to want to talk to you and
that was my that is literally what I
wrote down as sort of like an orderly
formal final question is like what is
the goal for each life or being a human
being at all but let's not start there
we can end there or we can start there
it doesn't matter but actually I'd like
to take a moment and go backwards
because I feel like we can spend lots of
time with like the information the data
and what to do but let's just go back in
time first and so let's talk about these
ancient temples ancient pyramids
um ancient structures
um and civilizations and what it what
what their role was I have I went to
Egypt
um two years ago
and I had always just like you I've been
fascinated with it I was a teenager and
wanted to go to Egypt and to see the
pyramids I didn't know why I didn't know
why I was so drawn to it I mean I can
watch The Mummy on you know the movie
The Mummy and be intrigued just because
it has to do with Egypt like yes I'm so
drawn to it so what was the role with
temples the role with you know the the
pyramids and the also putting in
perspective the locations of them as
well
yes so the ancient Egyptian temple
science was a qualitative science today
when we think about science we think
about it being quantitative but in the
ancient world they understood things in
terms of qualities of energy so there's
an energetic aspect that comes from
higher spiritual Realms higher spiritual
planes to create this world that gets
expressed in the powers of color and
shape and angle and proportion and
number sequences all these things are a
kind of divine code or Divine language
of this world in the ancient world in
every ancient tradition including
ancient Egypt they had systems of
initiation where people went through
certain
step-by-step processes that would expand
their Consciousness to higher levels so
they would begin to perceive themselves
as a multi-dimensional being operating
on multiple planes at the same time they
would begin to understand the way that
human consciousness can be developed
much much further than it is currently
to develop abilities that we tend to
think of today as magical and the human
Energy System can be developed much much
further
and to do things that again today would
be thought to be impossible in working
with natural forces
and so it kind of comes back I can
paraphrase the work of Arthur C Clarke
who he says any sufficiently advanced
form of technology that one does not
understand will appear to be magic
and that's very much the way it was in
ancient Egypt and these other ancient
cultures they thought about things in a
completely different way than we do and
that makes if you see things from a
different perspective it makes things
that seem to be impossible possible
and so there's a whole system of Temple
initiations in ancient Egypt that were
very advanced
and we need to understand some of the
fundamentals of what spiritual
initiation really is yeah so one aspect
of this has been almost forgotten today
is that when we do anything with our
Consciousness or our energy it starts to
create an energy pattern in our physical
body and our energy field
so whatever thoughts we keep generating
whatever their quality is
whatever energies we're generating with
our heart or with our actions in the
world
it's developing a pattern that then
creates a type of sacred geometric
structure in our energy field and so for
advanced
masters of this work they could check
out somebody's field and see what energy
structures are present so this is a very
simple way to explain that certain
chakras in their energy field would be
more activated or not very activated or
they would be balanced in a harmonious
way or they would be unbalanced or the
energy meridians and patterns in the
body would be fully open or they would
be blocked all of these things are
components of larger geometric patterns
that can be created in the human energy
field
and so this development of the
Consciousness and energy gets reflected
in energy patterns in a person's field
and that's the pearl of great price that
we can take through the gate of death
and then into a new rebirth and this is
a classic idea but this is like the
thing that really matters okay we can
just while away our time here and not
have it add up to much of anything and
we're no more advanced at the time of
death than we were when we came here in
the first place or we can do some really
serious development work with our
Consciousness and energy and become more
than we were before and again that gets
preserved in these energy patterns in
our field that's like the one thing you
take with you yeah so what's the
consequence of not improving in this
life so we can quickly hook more people
to listen
so that they understand how they can fix
their energy field and make progress and
improve the patterns of their life or
whatever those things are that we're
gonna you're gonna help us understand
there are many consequences but probably
the most fundamental thing that that'll
drive it home for everybody is that if
you do not use this lifetime for
advancing your state and you don't
understand the patterns of life then
basically you're just going to be
condemned to keep repeating the same
mistakes and you're going to repeat
yourself to an endless cycle of
suffering so that's one of the main
Concepts in Buddhism is how much
unnecessary suffering are we exposing
ourselves to by not striving for
enlightenment or not doing the basic
work to be able to observe and control
our mind to observe and control and
direct our feeling life to observe and
control our energy and our actions in
the world to control and direct our
speech
so this is really a universal concept
but for the Buddhists they talk about
skillful action take skillful action
you'll develop yourself to a place where
you have more pleasure you have more
freedom you understand how things work
and you can make an educated decision or
you can take unskillful action just be
in the reactive mind and react
emotionally to everything around you in
a way that's destructive and destroys
relationships destroys possibilities and
then you'll just stay on that cycle of
suffering so that's really the most
fundamental part of it but the other
part of it is there's a deeper aspect of
suffering beyond our usual day-to-day
experience and that is there's a type of
subtle suffering that comes by not
knowing Who We Are by not remembering
who we are why we're here what we chose
to do in this Incarnation this larger
spiritual context it's often very
subconscious in people but it drives
them to try to fill their lives with
other things that just become
destructive in the end well help us get
off the wheel of karma I'll do I'll do
what I can I'm working to get off it
myself but yes
I mean well is that I mean as
right now is that innate within the
human existence is that we will never be
able to fully see ourselves and remember
our past and remember where we came from
and who we are and that is confined
within this Dimension as part of the
human existence in the in our in our in
our challenge of this reality is that
part of this Matrix this was understood
in the ancient world in classical
initiation as what was referred to as
taking the draft of forgetfulness this
means that when you incarnate you are
made to forget who you are where you're
from what this whole purpose is your
past incarnations the whole thing I sure
do this classic understanding of the
draft of forgetfulness is the thing that
we come in not remembering now this is
not true for people of certain levels of
higher Spiritual Development because of
the structures they've created in their
subtle bodies they can bring in the
remembrance of who they are pretty much
from the beginning and these people can
recognize the people around them in
their lives from their connections with
them in previous lives and they they
maintain more of this knowledge but
that's based on certain structures you
create in the subtle body that takes
work it takes knowledge to to create
these now initiation one major part of
it has always been to go through a
remembering process in the European
rosicrucian tradition there's a great
initiation saying which is in the
beginning was the memory
that means the first thing that we have
to do when we come back every time is to
regain our karmic memory of who we are
because this is not our first rodeo
we've done this before and so there's
certain types of karmic exercises a
person can do to start to remember who
they are where they come from Etc and
that that gate is not as closed for some
people as it is for others and
particularly there's a lot of this going
on now because there's been such a
Resurgence of what in the ancient world
was particular types of plant medicine
that were used in initiation processes
and is now coming back with the mass use
of psychotropics often related to the
old plant medicine and that can often
help people regain their karmic memory
through certain activations
but the key thing here is to remember
again who we are why we're here because
otherwise you know it's like we're in
some movie where we're amnesic and we
have to go through this whole process of
where am I what's happened what's this
whole thing about but once we start to
remember that now we regain our purpose
and we begin to remember who we've been
and how that's led to here and that this
is itself only one bead in a chain
leading to a particular destination for
us to become a unique spiritual being in
the world
it's what from the Greek work is called
teleological destination it's like we're
being pulled towards what we're meant to
become in the future and all these
interesting things happen to us people
we meet and experiences that were given
and things we didn't expect appearing in
our lives helping to pull us toward this
and so like again in the old rosicrucian
initiation this was referred to as
reading the name and scribed on the
stone
and this is where we begin to remember
who we've been before now there's a lot
of challenges with this because it's
very easy for this to fall into fantasy
we were just projecting all types of
things about I'd like to be this I'd
like to be that so if people if their
first memories are something that's very
elevated like I was this fantastic
famous historical figure in the past and
I'm just drenched in glory then often
that should be questioned because when
you actually start doing past life
regression with people it's very common
that first thing they remember are
traumatic experiences being a scullery
made in 13th century France where you
were horribly abused this type of thing
but the larger aspect of it is that
there is a purpose to our series of
incarnations now again going to the
modern European rosicrucian tradition
which I believe is kind of
transformation of the old Egyptian
initiation the essene initiation the
Greek the Holy Grail tradition in Europe
into a modern format
there's a whole aspect of this where
human race has a esoteric name just like
the higher Angelic beings have names
that that point to what their power
their function is the name for the human
race and the rosicrucian tradition is
that we are spirits of love and freedom
and so that's one of the hardest
combinations to get right because love
is all about uniting and becoming one
with other other people other beings
and then freedom is the ability to
separate from other beings and make
completely independent decisions
now higher Spiritual Beings have the
ability to do something that another
teacher of mine Dr Samuel Sagan at the
Clear Vision School of Australia back in
the 90s I was training with him and he
had a concept called combinescence so
combined Essence common essence you may
perceive in spiritual perception that
there is what appears to be a gigantic
Angelic being some great spiritual being
but then you perceive that there are
other beings starting to peel out of
this larger spiritual being as
independent entities and you begin to
realize that non-physical Spiritual
Beings can actually unite together in a
combined energetic form that appears to
be one being but then they can separate
back out again into separate beings oh
my God now in a physical body we have a
very limited ability to do this but out
of the physical body as energy Fields
they can actually combine together and
so that's part of this thing of being
spirits of love and freedom we're
supposed to find the right Rhythm the
right ability to make Free Will choices
to be able to unite with another person
or persons to become the one again back
to the Divine plane back to the godhead
back to the original unified state where
we're all one and that's what we all
seek emotionally we want to find that
partner that we can become one with oh
like the combination of the energy that
we see as like one thing but we know
it's like when you say that I'm like yes
uh I was just you know I have done some
plant medicine ceremonies and recent
experience I had you know whenever I'm
explaining it it's a they
they want me to know but it seems
singular but it's a they yeah it just
you know it's an as you know it's a
collective energy but it seems as though
it's one voice in a way
so this is really part of the classical
knowledge about multiple planes of
creation at the highest level what in
the west we might call the Divine plane
everything is one there is no polarity
there is no Duality there's no yin yang
there's no masculine feminine there's no
separation of any kind everything is one
that's like the highest state that
people attain in psychotropic experience
but you feel like you became one again
and like the cosmic Ocean and the cosmic
being and it's a very real State and the
something that we yearned for that we
have embedded in us so something that we
yearn forward to experience with another
person or to experience in high
spiritual states to get back to that
state of Oneness but the level beneath
the Divine plane what we might call the
spiritual plane is where that Oneness
divides into multiplicity all the
different powers of the Divine or they
say in the Himalayas the sittas and so
at that level these are great beings
beings are the tremendously High stature
we think of them today as mythologic
the gods or these are these the you know
in ancient Greek stories or even ancient
Egypt stories like yes these are sort of
the gods are there are the are the
fractions of
a higher level higher dimension of
reality absolutely they're they're the
one divided into all of its separate
Powers functions qualities as conscious
beings on a very high spiritual level
so if you're in India you might talk
about the Shivan Shakti if you were in
ancient Egypt you would talk about the
netters the conscious powers of nature
these are all aspects of these higher
spiritual forces that then move down
through the plains until we get to more
microcosmic beings like ourselves
and so one of the Mysteries in the
ancient world is what they called the
The Mystery of the Black Cube how is it
that we're amnesiacs in this physical
world and we begin to realize that we're
a spiritual being having a spiritual
experience in the physical body in a
physical world and how did I get here
and so this mystery of the Black Cube is
on how higher beings create a space-time
enclosure for us to move into as young
Spiritual Beings going through an
educational process like going to
kindergarten so everything's brightly
colored and solid and so we become very
self-aware in this process
but it's really the whole question of
how we are able to attain self-awareness
and then attain The Higher Goals of
developing both love and freedom and
that becomes part of what well in the
Chinese tradition they call the nine
heart pains the things that become the
most challenging for us in life we're
all going to seek that partner that we
can become one with again and unify with
and have that love with because love is
all about unification into the one no
separation but then you have to have the
freedom and you've got to be able to
have your own time in your own space and
make your own decisions and not just
give yourself over to another person
that Rhythm of Love And Freedom
particularly in Intimate Relationships
you know is one of the greatest
challenges in life it can have the
greatest Pleasures in life but it can
also have the greatest pain but the
whole of human life is really about how
do we balance love and freedom service
to others and self-development without
flying off into Mass narcissism in one
sense or at least using our freedom and
Independence and the other polarity
codependency so let's talk about how to
do that
how do we how do we evolve spiritually
geometrically pattern wise are I've
heard you talk about you know our energy
structure
um so I'm not sure the right exact
direction to go this is the hard thing
about interviewing you is you are so
wise and knowledgeable about so many
things it's hard to know exactly which
way to point the ship but
um
maybe thank you
um bear with me
um maybe what creates our energy
structure is that something passed down
from lifetimes is this something created
is this something
through DNA and our parents in some way
genetically
um what is it that creates our energy
structure and you know then of course
the probably roll into how do we change
that or how do we evolve that how do we
grow so that we can
reach a point and
space and time with our bodies uh that
we can then be confident and comfortable
and know ourself well enough to be able
to uh unite but be free and not only do
that with ourselves but in but with
someone else because freedom is the
having giving the other person Freedom
too
yes absolutely so one of the core
aspects of this and thank you very much
for the kinds so true it's just like I
could just listen to you for hours and
and I have but thank you I appreciate
that so again this all comes back to the
study of patterns there's a reason why
every classical tradition teaches sacred
geometry because if you don't understand
the pattern of something you have no
ability to co-create with it or to use
it for your own benefit you're just a
victim of that and again that's true for
everything in life whether it's
relationships finances Health everything
is based on this including our Spiritual
Development the problem we have today is
what I often refer to
as the blessing and the curse that we
actually have more access to different
schools of spiritual knowledge today
than at any previous time in recorded
human history stuff that you would have
to go to incredible links in the past to
like go to another country and try to be
accepted into a temple and have them
teach you and they wouldn't even teach
you the main stuff for 10 years now you
can buy a book on it it's incredible
exactly and so for example the higher
level Chinese Taoist internal Alchemy
systems which are some of the most
advanced energetic work in the world was
super hidden until the 1980s and then it
began to be published today you can get
books about it you can go to courses on
it used to be super hidden your work
even being with covet I remember you
talking about how making that platform
available instead of doing things in
person it created such a such a bigger
reach it really did so again there's
blessings and curses involved so the the
blessing of this is that we have
incredible access to very deep spiritual
knowledge and practice information that
in the past would have been almost
impossible for us to access
so for those of us that are really
excited and stimulated about these types
of possibilities this is an amazing time
to be alive
but the curse of it is that a lot of
this information didn't come out in a
whole form it came out in these broken
fragments and so and a lot of the way
the information is coming out is either
slightly twisted or corrupted or just
plain wrong or it's a half truth that's
sometimes more dangerous than a complete
pulsive that's partly why the
information was held tightly and usually
given verbally is because that way it
could they wanted to make sure that the
people that were getting it were able to
use it responsibly and not manipulate
people with it because it's very
powerful technology that's absolutely
right is that you had I mean they didn't
even teach you the main stuff for years
because they had to test the quality of
your character because again you could
misuse this knowledge terribly and and
so that was one reason why it was kept
hidden and in these very close
initiation systems
but again we have this uh the blessing
of the access to the knowledge but the
curse that is completely fragmented
today okay and so we have to put it back
together into a unified whole because if
we don't understand how the pieces fit
together again we don't have what we
need to make informed decisions we have
very limited time and energy in our
Earthly life and we have to be able to
make informed decisions about what's the
most important things I need to learn
what's the most important things I need
to experience yes what's the most
important practices for me to do because
there's a bazillion practices you could
do out there overwhelming it can be but
if you can put it into a context if you
can see how it all fits back together
then you can navigate in an informed way
through it and that's part of what I
created The bessica Institute for I
don't claim to have all the universal
knowledge but it's meant to put the
pieces back together yeah to be able to
express in the most clear concise form
possible so that people can make
informed decisions and under understand
how those those pieces do fit together
today
and so
going to your question about well what's
this about it where's our energy body
come from so every human being once we
understand those patterns once we see
the larger context again that's why
sacred geometry is so important because
it's really the study of patterns not
only metaphysical patterns but also
those for our daily life in the physical
world so every human being is based on
the same
sacred geometry pattern which as I
describe in the Gaia series is a thought
form in the mind of God from the high
Divine plane level that then manifests
down through the plains as a particular
pattern of energy and Consciousness we
all have that exact same blueprint
that's why we all have the same chakras
the same energy meridians acupuncture
points Etc it's exact same blueprint for
all of us because originally we were all
one we were all one in the Divine plane
with the godhead and the unified field
were all one there but or was sometimes
described as the pleasure of the godhead
the pleasure of the one we separated out
into separate beings so that we could
magnify our experience as separate
beings and we think we're a completely
individual and separate from everything
else for a period of time so that we can
now develop in a fractal way
as separate beings and magnify the whole
experience set of everyone and
everything
so we all have the exact same blueprint
that gives us the capacity for
Consciousness energy
making Free Will choices but also
unifying back to the one if we choose to
or learn how to and so that Universal
pattern of energy can then be
individualized and so every act that we
take every thought that we generate
every emotion we generate every action
we take actually creates an emanation of
a particular quality of energy out of
our energy field that's why some people
are very pleasurable to be around
because but they're emanating out from
the quality of their thoughts their
feelings their actions and something
that feels good to be around for other
people it may not feel so good because
you can get caught in the reactive mind
a lot of detrimental trauma-based
aggressive fearful whatever States but
it's always being projected out of the
field
so whatever we do on a regular basis
begins to etch these patterns into our
energy field certain energy centers
become hyper activated some others
become sedated not properly active and
so we begin to individualize in a
idiosyncratic way our own Energy System
and our own consciousness
and so we then become more and more
individual beings as we go along and
that's considered by higher Spiritual
Beings to be something very beautiful
yeah I've heard it expressed before that
you know for us the higher Spiritual
Beings are our religion
but the religion for the higher
Spiritual Beings is the human race we're
like we're like their children and so
they love you see that but wow they love
looking at us and seeing how is this
person going to use their free will to
become a unique being in the universe a
being that has equality that's different
from any other being that exists because
it's a part of them it's a part of them
but it also is creating something new at
the same time and so it's like this is
like the opposite is this like in
contrast to entropy this is sort of like
is this like a balancing Force to
entropy it is it is no we look at only
one side of this equation in modern
physics so like we look at gravity and
and we understand the Gravity Force but
there's no discussion of the levity
Force but levity is an opposite force
that exists just as much as as gravity
and and so if the higher Spiritual
Beings if we're their religion it's this
whole question of if we truly become at
the end of our process of incarnations a
spirit of love and freedom then we have
the capacity to be a unique being in the
universe with unique capacities and the
metaphor that I often use with this is
that all snowflakes are crystallized
water
but every snowflake crystallizes in a
completely unique pattern that is never
duplicated
so every human being is becoming a
unique being without many overlaps well
you know everybody's got a different
flavor to them you know if you really
experience that internally different
people have what it's called the
Himalayas a different nectar they have a
different vibrational quality right and
so they become unique beings in the
universe and then our interactions with
them our energy field particularly in
higher tantric work our energy field
connecting to their energy field makes
something unique in that energetic
blending because we're two separate
fields to begin with and what comes out
of that Union of the field is then
another amazing thing so when we
co-create with another person and
whatever work we do with another person
whether it's highly intimate or more
external you know we can create these
amazing unique things and there's a
mystery then about human relationships
is this perhaps where because there's in
some spiritual spaces people talk about
how
powerful it will be if even just one
couple comes to two people come together
in this unified way become one and and
and the frequency and the pattern that
that creates will be so very very
powerful that even just one set of this
can make a difference because when you
take I'm thinking about like how
cymatics and how when a structure goes
from one form to another a new more
complicated form it kind of does it kind
of gets messy and then re-establishes at
a more complicated level but if you put
two people together you're adding
essentially two Fields together that
inherently create a new
higher dimensional more complicated form
that creates a unique new energetic
structure uh and also there's a very
important part of this that I want to
bring out which is
we've gone from a Unity state to a
duality State and when you're in a
duality State you always have a magnetic
attraction to the opposite polarity
you always have that magnetic attraction
that's what that's what allows us to
grow and develop and have some passion
in life you know keep looking for the
stuff but there's an aspect of this
whenever you bring two opposite
polarities together
there's a gating effect that happens
when the two opposite polarities come
together and connects to the one it
creates a type of a spiritual gate so
that's one of the secrets of what we
would think today as like higher level
Tantra two people joined their energy
Fields together when the two opposite
polarities mixed together they can open
up this higher dimensional gate and
allow in energies forces of Vortex from
higher worlds
so this is something of great
significance so for example in my uh
Gaia series I talk about a very
important energy practice of creating a
toroidal
circulation around the energy field now
this already exists yeah but a lot of
fundamental practices are about becoming
conscious of what already exists and now
co-creating with it and making it
stronger making it better fixing how
we've screwed it up unconsciously and so
we can do it from the Earth to the
heavens circulation or the Heavens to
the Earth but I brought out in the
series that it's rarely spoken about
that the highest level of this is to do
both simultaneously and when you have
that Yin and the young circulations
passing through each other they create a
zero point which opens up a gate of
energy really a hyperdimensional gate to
another world does this take two people
though because I I'm thinking about I'm
actually second I'm thinking about sex
magic and the things that I've learned
about about taking the energy and you
can push it in a more masculine
Direction up or a more feminine
Direction down and so does it take
two people creating the opposite
toroidal fields that intersect or is
this about you doing it yourself because
that seems very hard well this it's
actually both so it was understood in
the classical tradition that there's
solo cultivation the work we need to do
on ourselves and we got to do a certain
amount of work on ourselves or we're not
able to do higher level work with other
people we're just too screwed up so it's
really true so there's a certain amount
of solo cultivation we can do and when
we do things like in the energy field
have the toroidal fields pass through
each other then we can do that in our
own field and we can feel some of that
that opening of that gate just through
that in our own field yeah another very
important part of our working on
ourselves and then I'll get to the part
about the Dual cultivation
is that we tend to get stuck in the west
today with healing
and somehow healing has become this idea
that it's almost like a goal in itself
it's like the you know we're just
healing forever and that's true to a
certain extent there's layers of the
onion and we'll keep on healing as
things go but I found out years ago if I
put the word healing in the name of a
class I offer I'll get three times as
many people as if I don't and it's like
people are somehow this conscious or
subconscious idea that it's like
everything is all about just healing
heal heal heal
but and that's fine it's absolutely
essential because if we don't heal we
don't become whole because the root of
the word heal in the ancient languages
is the word whole we have to become
whole again and the trauma that we
suffer coming into physical Incarnation
as an amnesiac as a completely helpless
little infant and God knows what kind of
family and situations that you probably
chose
probably chose it but nonetheless it has
an impact and we have to become whole
again so we're not just like crazy
reactive mind emotional suffering so
healing is essential I'm not putting
down healing but we lost the context of
that healing is just the first stage so
again this is in Solo cultivation
healing is the first stage where we have
to become whole enough that our energy
field and our Consciousness is coherent
once we're coherent and basically to
some degree have our together then
we can actually do the real work and so
we might refer to that next stage as
activation activation is where we start
to activate all of our latent potential
all of our latent power all of the
latent energy centers in the body Each
of which hold a particular Sitta they
hold a particular power in our different
energy centers of the body every chakra
every acupuncture Point there's a power
there which is why That's the basis of
healing systems in India and China
activate the power of that point all
kind of things can happen so activation
is the next stage
Beyond just the healing then activation
itself is not enough because you can
find people doing plant medicine and
things and activating all kinds of stuff
sure but but their lives are still in
chaos because the next stage is to
stabilize stabilization is the next
stage so you have to heal enough to
become coherent then you need to start
activating your latent potential the
powers of the Mind the power of the
energy field and then what you've
activated has to be stabilized and then
at that point you're getting something
that will stay with you throughout your
life throughout your incarnations past
the gate of death as a permanent thing
in your structure so let's put all that
on the side of solo cultivation then
like you were talking about with Sex
Magic we have the Dual cultivation and
that's where higher level work can only
be done with another person
and so some aspects of this are
reflected in spiritual teachings like in
the Christian tradition where they say
when two or more gather together in my
name I am there with you type of thing
you can't it can't be done the higher
level Work Connection to these higher
forces can't be done solo it has to be
done with another person now that is
then bringing together the two opposite
polarities whatever polarity you chose
to Incarnate in whatever polarity the
other person has and you bring those
polarities together to open up the
gating of that field and again the
highest level of this is to get to the
point that you're no longer conscious of
your physical body at all you're
conscious of yourself as an energy field
and the other person is an energy field
both are specific qualities then the two
common nests together into one and it
becomes a state of complete Oneness this
is the state of the highest Bliss with
another person all the other things are
building up to it all the basic stuff in
a relationship and then the sexual stuff
and you keep building up becomes more
energetic it becomes more spiritual and
then when you get to the point that you
unify into the one you've managed to
open up a tremendous force that can
greatly accelerate the process of
development for both people and it
generates a force out into the world
that like you were talking about when
two people do this work and generate
this power it's like you have one nodal
point in a great grid of nodal points
that's now lit up and becomes activated
and helps to activate the other points
in the grid now this is also a link to
sacred geometry so like in the
rosicrucian tradition they talk about
the minimum number of people to form a
group that would change the world would
be 12 people it takes 12 different
perspectives on the same reality number
isn't it yes it takes 12 different
perspectives on the same reality to be
able to understand all the possible
aspects of it because you don't
understand it from just one aspect then
you're the Blind Men of the elephant you
know you think the elephant is a wall or
a spear or something you gotta have 12
different perspectives and know what the
thing really is that's why there's like
12 disciples around Christ
and so that harmonic number of 12 is
very significant that's why there's 12
signs of a zodiac 12 different
perspectives on the Sun
and so
this then moves to the point that if you
had 12 groups of 12 on the earth for the
144 that would really transform
the Earth's energetic field so this is
all based again it doesn't seem that
hard you wouldn't think it would be that
does not seem that hard 12 groups of 12
that are able to so like let's talk
about let's get like a little nuanced
with that like what is that group of 12
achieving you say all the aspects like
how can that happen
so again the classical idea on this says
that every person would bring a
different perspective into it naturally
they already do though right like let's
just naturally they already bring a
unique perspective they do but on an
archetypal level one would have more of
the power and perspective of Aries one
would have the power and perspective of
Taurus those types of things and then
you got the Unity coming together in a
microcosm
and that comes together into a very
powerful whole
but the challenge of this is that if you
ever worked in a spiritual organization
before things tend to always get screwed
up in spiritual organizations because of
people's Petty ego conflicts and all
this type of thing it's very hard to
work in spiritual organizations because
you have to deal with all these
different personalities but again this
is the archetype it certainly would be
possible it's often easier to start on
the Dual cultivation finding that one
other person to do this work with how
does how does polyamory work I mean come
on you can't even it's hard enough to
make it work with one other person let
alone a couple like
well the whole thing I think with uh the
polyamory movement that we have today is
that it does have a very important
deconstruction aspect to it which is
that in our culture today we have so
many thought forums and programmings
about we're going to have one other
person that's going to perform every
function we ever needed to have brought
into our life everything to make us feel
loved and whole and everything you want
to experience they'll share all of that
with us and this becomes a huge burden
we put on somebody else like this one
other person supposed to fulfill all of
my needs in life yeah yeah very unfair
so it can it can be really rough and
this also then leads to the whole thing
where we start as I talked about in the
episode in the Gaia series on sacred
geometry relationship we start casting
people into our own psychodrama so like
this person is going to get cast into
the role of my the bad mommy this is the
bad daddy this is all the things that I
need to work on my conflict with and I'm
not going to tell you about it but I'm
going to project all this on top of you
so I think this idea of polyamory is is
something that actually is part of a
spiritual progression if it's done in an
ethical and healthy way of being able to
get out of the grasping of someone to
you must perform this role for me to
leaving them free but finding a way to
unite so is it a transient phase for
humans to move closer to love and
freedom or
uh path like actually a landing place
for love and freedom is it a part is it
on the path to love and freedom so that
you can be able to do that with one
person or is that actually what where
you end up when you get to love and
freedom I don't know if I have a
completely solid answer to it but it's
one of those things where in the end
we're gonna have to explore all kinds of
different things to get to the final
result we have to be able to extend our
flexibility in all kinds of directions
in life you know this is the heretical
aspect of the Prodigal Son teaching from
the Christian tradition that most
mainstream Christians completely ignore
because it's simply too heretical and
too dangerous to say that the you know
the Sun that went and experienced all
kinds of crazy stuff in life is more
esteemed by the father than the one that
stayed behind exactly and got all the
and got the and got the big big big big
party when he came home that's right not
the best coward calf or whatever it was
and you know slaughtered that one and so
so no doubt at the end we're going to
have to experience all these different
things to get the maximum flexibility I
mean some people may disagree with me
but this is all just my perspective and
so the we're going to have to have that
experience of focusing on just one
person and seeing how far we can take
that at some point in our incarnations
but also this aspect about being able to
be free and explore where we feel
connections with multiple people in a
way that is not constrained by all of
these societal conditionings I think is
a part of the natural growth of humanity
right now that's extremely healthy
because when you see the amount of
suffering that people have based on
these ideas you have to stay with one
person forever they're going to fulfill
all of your needs and even though you've
been absolutely miserable and are just
waiting for death after being together
for 30 years you've still got to stick
together I'm not sure that that actually
leads to a better outcome
the I just got done I interviewed David
Buss today who's an evolutionary
psychologist and he said they he was
just explaining the exact same thing
where you know say you are in a
monogamous relationship for a very very
long time most of those people are
really happy yes yes so common so common
and again when a person is at a
particular state of solo cultivation and
can find people that they're a match
with I mean that's that's magic and
that's another thing I think is very
important because it's so easy
particularly when relationships fail
it's so painful when intimate
relationships fail it's very easy to
fall into this type of country music
story about oh she done me wrong and my
person that loves me is my dog and it
becomes like this type of very lower
Consciousness thing about I'm the hero I
was in the right they were in the wrong
they're the villain but yeah and you
know there are abusive relationships
where that could be the case but most of
the time it says it comes down to the
very simple fact that it wasn't a match
and people match on different levels
people may match more toward a physical
or energetic level more sexual level
they may match more emotionally or
mentally or spiritually and hopefully
they may match on all kinds of different
levels that would be be awesome for a
little while until you change and then
they don't match anymore exactly the
only constant is change and you know one
of the worst things they ever say to
somebody in a relationship is you
changed and like that's not permitted
you have to stay who you were before and
all of the pledges you made when you
were a different person you now have to
to stick with even though you're a
completely different person now we can't
freeze a person in place so I think it's
really healthy to get out of the who's
right who's wrong and the relationship
breakups and just recognize it's not a
match anymore
and then it becomes something really
clean it's like do you match with this
person if so explore it on whatever
level it's a match if you're not a match
with the person admit it and save your
both of you the suffering and and move
on in whatever Direction you need to go
relationships and matching and being
triggered
and growing
and the old saying we don't see things
as they are we see things as we are all
right yeah I'll explain that explain
that expression and how true that how
that
can be explained
from a geometrical pattern sense
because everything splits into polarity
from Unity this also happens with
developing our Consciousness and there's
two aspects then there's a essential
polarity to develop our consciousness
and so whether we see things as they
actually are or just see them as our
projections
is related to our needing to develop two
types of
meditative practices
the first type is the type that was
primarily developed in the East and that
is receptive meditation receptive
meditation is things like Zen or
vipassana or Transcendental Meditation
you're not generating any thought forms
in fact you're holding your mind
completely clear the mind becomes a
clear mirror and they say in Zend for
example that you're developing the
ability to have a direct view of reality
without any filters
at an objective one a real objective
view a real objective view of reality
what's actually right in front of you at
that moment without all of your
projections about what's right what's
wrong what do I want this person to do
or not do all of these types of embedded
perspectives that we carry with us so a
true receptive meditation is getting
into a clear mind state where the mind
is often likened to like a clear sky or
to the surface of pure water as a pure
mirror and we learn how to not project
our own content onto people or
situations and just see it in its
reality so receptive meditation is
absolutely essential and it's what's
really been focused on more in the East
and the west then the other side of it
equally important but completely
different
complementary polarity is the act of
meditation active meditation is things
like what we think of today as creative
visualization it's really the ability to
create a thought form
now this can be a magical power the
thought forms that we create can change
the reality in our own lives they
certainly change the reality inside of
us they can start to change the reality
outside of us too if we create a
coherent enough thought form it all gets
projected out every thought every
emotion we ever have gets projected out
of our field out into the world it
happens automatically for all energetic
beings the power of this is now you can
begin to take action through the
crafting of thought forms and of course
you have to take action to manifest it
in the world but the thought form is the
beginning of the process it has a power
of its own as well isn't that it's
that's in and of itself is an action it
is it is but then we also can take
action with our feeling life and our
ability to take action with the physical
body out in the world to manifest
anything we ever dreamed of
and so the thing is that we have to have
both aspects of this and the thing is
that almost all Traditions today will
only teach one or the other and if the
other side of it even comes up they'll
tend to ridicule the other side the
people that do the Creative
visualizations just kind of mock the the
clear mind State stuff is oh you know
they're not achieving anything they're
not doing anything it doesn't have a
purpose and the people in the clear mind
States say look at those people doing
all the the platform generation work
they're not even able to see what's
right in front of their face and they're
both right so this is again the fractal
another another another example of
Duality it's another example of Duality
and you can't just pick one Duality and
say that's good and the other is bad
it's always the union of the two
dualities to get back to the one or what
the Tibetans would call the middle path
the middle way right that that creates
the miracle when the two come together
and so that would be my my main
geometric answer to this is you have to
develop both types of receptive and
active meditation and just like
breathing in and breathing out or
stepping with the left foot and the
right foot that's how you get somewhere
one of the things that for me has been a
big big shift in my experience
in this life of of My reality going
through it each day is becoming the
Observer it's really like
not taking things personally not
projecting and I'm not saying not at all
I'm just saying less I should say
um because I'm Still Human but to be
able to really see from an observer
perspective the dynamic that's really
existing and how you know if somebody is
irritated with you because you know your
dog's off of a leash well instead of
reacting and being I got it like
seriously like I have an electric collar
on them I trust me I've said this I'm
like if I put this collar on you you'd
listen to maybe I've said that before
but to know like to have enough
perspective and wisdom and observer
perspective now to go wow I am either
they've been hurt before in this
scenario so they're protecting
themselves or they would never never go
against the rules of the road and they
would always have their dog on a leash
because they're a rule follower so now
I've triggered them because they would
never do what I'm doing and so they
believe that I should live the same way
and so like I see so how can I progress
that Observer more objective perspective
in life and and how can how can one kind
of get get on that path because I've
felt for myself it's been really
valuable for just staying calm in so
many more situations and not not
creating drama
I think that is so incredibly important
for us not to generate conflict and so
part of it again is the receptive
meditation to get to where we hold a
clear mind State because even if people
are very annoyed with you and acting
aggressively it changes the energetic
situation if you're completely calmed
balanced not reactive but then it needs
to go to another level
and this is what is one of the teachings
from the Holy Grail tradition of Europe
very misunderstood today often very
misinterpreted as a as a bloodline type
of thing but the real Holy Grail
tradition had to do a certain types of
Spiritual Development to get to a higher
level regardless of any Bloodlines and
one part of this is what they call the
speech of the Grail
so there were Knights of the sword who
cut with the sword and you can in your
relationships cut people with your
comments and your actions and try to
dominate them and be right and make them
wrong and enforce your perspective on
top of those be a might of the sword or
you can be a knight of the word and the
night of the word is the more advanced
level in The Grail tradition and that's
where you develop the speech of the
Grail it's a dynamic ability
to think on your feet and to find a way
to communicate to other people in a way
that heals and enlightens them that any
any case of conflict that we have with
another person if we can keep the clear
mind State and then use the speech of
the grill so that we don't cast them in
the in a role of some inferior being
while we're the superior being but we're
two human beings going through our
experience and we keep an open heart and
an open connection with them and speak
to them in a way that clearly reflects
our perspective while also respecting
and honoring them in a way that
hopefully brings light rather than heat
to the situation that's another major
part of it and again there's a lot of
this is based on the development of the
heart can we find a way to keep our
heart open and communicating to another
person without caricaturing them in a
particular conflict situation in a way
that respects of even if what they're
doing is absolutely absurd and
destructive
but it's like the concept of Namaste
from India Namaste meaning that the
Divine in me sees and respects the
Divine in you that we're actually any
time that we Direct Energy to the Divine
plain we activate that energy so there's
ways to do that like in biogeometry and
in in energy work to connect to those
points and activate them but in this
case what we are talking about is
whenever you're with another person and
you are actively seeing their Divine
core their Divine self no matter how
screwed up they are and how badly
they're acting out which is essentially
seeing the best in them right is that is
that a way to like sort of bring that to
a tangible sort of way way of thinking
it is seeing the best in them but it
does literally become seeing the Divine
Light in them as a very literal act
seeing the Divine Light and core and
knowing that they come come from the
same one that we came from as an
absolute internal knowing not like an
abstract idea but like feeling it in the
heart and it's like the way that the
Buddhists get over uh conflict like they
have ways to solve anger and so they
talk about one of the first things we
have to do to overcome being angry with
another person is to ask ourselves how
they suffer
and once you start seeing how the
person's actions are coming out of their
suffering no matter how badly they're
being destructive it's easier to work
with it is it easy to say always for
that it's always coming from their pain
their their challenges their suffering
yes because for some people the best
defense is a good offense yeah are these
what would be like bio signatures in
someone or what are bio signatures okay
so now we're we'll move into the ideas
of Egyptian uh biogeometry and so
the knowledge of what was done in the
ancient Egyptian temples was basically
lost and they have a saying in Egypt
that our Mysteries were never betrayed
meaning that what was secret in the
temple stayed secret in the temple fair
enough we'll remember
absolutely that's what we're doing right
now is we're remembering this now it's a
very interesting thing just on the road
to answering your question that you know
for myself and for many other people who
begin to remember past lives one of the
first past lives they remember is
Egyptian now I find that fascinating
because we've had other past lives more
recently why don't we remember those
first there's something about the
Egyptian incarnations that are so
significant to us would the energetic
frequency that we lived in that life be
so loud as maybe the like of just a
slang word but so such a high frequency
such a standout frequency that we're
picking up at that energetic signature
in our past first because it's like the
most complicated the most Progressive
could it be that I do think that's one
part of it many of the images you see in
classical religions are sacred geometry
forms that have a deeper meaning or
teaching behind them but only the
initiates are taught the deeper meaning
the average person only understands a
surface level example the original
Jewish menorah from the Jewish
kabbalistic tradition so there's seven
candlesticks the first one is connected
in a great Arc to the seventh one the
second in a great Arc to the sixth the
third in a great Arc to the fifth and
the fourth one stands alone now the
Jewish capitalistic tradition has a very
deep understanding of Time and Time
cycle and so what this embeds is that
certain periods of time are divided into
seven stages like a seven stage
alchemical process and time cutting to
the chase you're all going into all the
details in the time since the Atlantean
catastrophe and the Western tradition
misunderstood for example with the
European resecrutions that the third
post-atlancian Epoch was the Egyptian
eat puck
and the one we're at now is the fifth
Epoch the European Epoch where the
Europeans became the dominant people
that's what we're in now that's right
and so there's a connection between the
third and the fifth because it's like
the fourth is the dividing point it's
like a mirror image so the third and the
fifth are mirrors of each other second
and the sixth first and the seventh
without going into all the other details
of it this means that we're in a part of
a Time cycle right now where if you
understand the greater structure of the
time cycle is we're having a certain
type of reflection going the opposite
direction of what we had in ancient
Egypt and so we have a natural
fascination with our time in ancient
Egypt and if you turn on you know some
documentary channel on TV the vast
majority of documentaries about ancient
cultures are all about Egypt there's
very very few about ancient Persia and
other cultures are all about Egypt but
that's because that's being reawakened
in us the knowledge we had then but now
in a later stage of evolution so there's
all of this hidden sacred geometry
patterns of time as well as in space
so that's my answer to the whole thing
about you know why is the Egyptian so
important now let's go into them more I
I like to I want to I want to understand
this better
so
since you're the this year they're such
the perfect person for this because you
you look at things in the way that it
feels tangible for me which is through
patterns and energy and
it's tangible thing while we can't see
it I can feel it I know it I believe it
I be I know it
um so how is it that we're connecting to
these different time space react time
space realities the third and the fifth
the first and the seventh these things
how explain that from a geometric
standpoint from a pattern standpoint
so when you have a cycle of seven
there's a natural relationship where the
very first stage gets reflected in the
in the last stage
it's a it's a polarity relationship
everything's polarities right yep sure
so you're coming in and you're going out
they talk about that with dimensions a
lot where yes um like the the last come
next back to the first again that's
always the case okay as it's like the
oroboros eating its tail sort of thing
so you've got the the first of the
seventh are connected again and the
menorah's got a great Arc showing you
they're connected and so the first
person Epoch was the Indian Epoch with
the time of the oldest book in the world
the laws of Manu and the creation of the
great civilization of the Indus Valley
and The Vedic culture second was the
Persian zoroastrian tradition the third
was the Egyptian the fourth was the
Greco-Roman and the fifth is the current
European and then there's more to come
with the sixth and the seventh on the
way and so it's always the case then
that the fourth just as shown in the
menorah as the dividing line in the
center is the place that the whole
process inverts what was coming in is
now going out
and so there's a a development the
opposite direction
in those later stages so all of us in
that have these recollections
of ourselves in ancient Egypt there's a
part of that that's being activated
right now now once we get into if we're
incarnating let's say in the sixth
post-atlantean Epoch we may be much more
focused on our ancient Persian
incarnations that's something that will
be called up inside of us there's a
great idea in what's called uh Vedic
astrology or jyotish in India which
which is uh that is there are certain
moments in time where your Karma's will
ripen your karmas will be activated they
have a whole science of this in in India
of the Dasha periods it doesn't exist in
Western astrology at all but in the
Indian system you can get your dashes
read and you'll know what karma is going
to ripen at what moment of your life
certain experiences will happen then
same thing for us with our whole
Incarnation right now there's a certain
karma that's ripening from ancient Egypt
having to do with the abilities we gain
there remembering regaining those
abilities bringing them to bear in our
lives right now and bringing them to
prayer on the earth to help the Earth as
a whole right now
so that's that's the basic idea that so
do we continue to add these memories so
let's say we move from the fifth we pick
up all of the information in the third
by the time we complete the fifth we
reintegrate it we've reintegrated the
third with the fifth then we go to the
sixth we've kept that information
and now we go into the sixth and we pick
up the fourth is that right the the
sixth and the second six in the second
so now we pick the we pick up the second
and so we continue to pick it up until
we arrive at the end of these time
cycles and
then and then I said that's right
I have this like I'm so un incapable
because I don't understand it well
enough I can't explain it simply
but maybe this will strike something in
you but I think about reality in the
sense of fractals a lot yes then when I
put into that when I add in quantum
entanglement which is just so hard to
understand and comprehend because it's
so beyond our scope of imagination of
what's really possible then I start to
think about
black holes
and I start to think about like time
looping like reality like time and space
looping and so is there anything within
the fabric of reality with geometry or
anything like that that would create
looping because like quantum
entanglement to think two two particles
acting instantaneously in the equal and
opposite way is just such a hard thing
to understand so there must be something
that closes the gap between what we
would look at between point a and point
B and there must be sitting on top of
each other in some way
that's right it's the whole idea of the
unified field is that those two
particles that are affecting each other
uh are part they're connected through a
much larger Matrix and again this is why
in my sacred geometry series on Gaia the
very first episode was about the net the
Matrix of creation that everything is a
part of so we have an aspect of this
where everything is integrally linked in
a larger energetic and spiritual system
that modern science has no concept of
they only look at the broken fragments
that appear into physical reality they
look at the collapse of the wave
function where the energetic waves have
become a physical object but they no
longer understand the larger Matrix that
the waves are in including at the higher
Consciousness levels before a wave that
created the physical world even came to
into existence
so understanding it from the classical
traditions of multiple planes of
existence all of which we participate in
we all have those within ourselves and
can experience all of them as a way to
understand this and fractals is a modern
concept that really helps us to
understand how the same pattern at a
higher level of scale the same pattern
at a higher uh plane level manifest here
on this plane with the same pattern but
reduced in scale
I'll give you a particular example of an
idea of fractal reality from
2000 years ago in Alexandria Egypt in
the early Christian centuries when they
were trying to understand what is the
nature of the Christ being in early
Christianity one of the great now called
a Church Father origin living in
Alexandria Egypt with an incredible book
called on first principles and in it he
says the only way you can understand
what the Christ being is we're not
talking about the master Jesus as a
human being we're talking about this
larger cosmological being the solar
logos the Christ being says the way to
understand what this being is is that
the godhead is so vast the godhead is
everything it's so vast that you don't
get a
a a view of what that being is because
it's everything everywhere
he says what the Christ being is is a
macrocosmic being that has all the
qualities of the godhead but reduced in
scale to the macrocosmic level to where
we can actually perceive and interact
with this being
and in humanity also has the qualities
of the godhead but we're reduced to the
microcosmic level we're another level
reduced but it's the exact same fractal
pattern and so we are microcosmic beings
with all the potentials of the godhead
Laden inside of us most of which have
been neutralized because people are so
screwed up today if you actually have
these higher Powers you'd create
incredible destruction all around you
but this idea that it's a fractal
movement from one level to another is an
ancient concept but today we can express
it in geometry and math and and get it
as a visual hit that's why I like
describing the idea about how the seven
time periods in a cycle work together by
giving the geometric form and that's why
they thought in ancient Judaism too
which is why they gave the image of the
menorah they didn't explain to the
average person what it meant that was
for the initiative to understand that's
the structure of time Cycles is there
something to be said about these
geometric structures even being in Egypt
they said that the you know the
um you know the Ram or any of the heads
of the Lions of the of the animals were
were actually
geometrically activating something
within you when you looked at it is
there something happening by just
observing these structures these
patterns these
um these actual physical things sitting
in front of us that will activate
something within us absolutely so for
this let me go to the work of
biogeometry and my friend and teacher in
Egypt Dr Abraham Karim and he's got some
amazing work on this within the the
biogeometry work so what aspect of this
is that he talks about the way that in
ancient Egypt they knew an incredible
secret and that secret was the design
code behind everything in creation the
design code that allows you to
crystallize physical forums into a
physical world from higher energetic
States
and that this became expressed through
things like the hieroglyphic text and
through some of the Expressions that
they had with design in ancient Egypt
and so there are certain energy
emanations coming from certain
hieroglyphs that if you test it with
energetic methods like vibrational
radiusthesia where you can detect subtle
energy waves coming off of things some
of these hieroglyphs have very powerful
energetic waves coming out from them
because of the shape information oh wow
like the in
the ends into the wall
of it and create energetic structure it
creates an energetic effect so like
you're saying if you look at it doesn't
have an effect on you and the answer is
yes so they found ways to work with
shape information to be able to bring
forward all types of energy states so in
biogeometry to explain how we get the
effects we get with the work one of the
the concepts that we use developed by Dr
Kareem is that energy into shape creates
function
so energy is a proteus it could take any
form but how do we program the energy to
do a specific thing we have that energy
move in a specific pattern so the energy
movement pattern programs the energy to
take the action now that's why your
heart has a specific geometric shape
that's completely different from the
shape of the liver that's different from
the shape of the spleen Because the
actual shape is related to the function
oh
and so that's what biosignatures are you
mentioned earlier biosignatures from
just cycling back to that so so what
matters yeah it absolutely matters it's
like it's like Forum follows function
right so energy into shape creates
function
so the shape of everything matters and
any two things with a similar shape can
exchange energy and information now
that's the idea that we have today in
electromagnetic Theory we have to have a
specifically shaped antenna to pick up a
specific electromagnetic signal if it
doesn't have the right shape it can't
pick up the signal but that's true
energetically with all living beings all
right so heart connection like a heart
to heart coherence exactly exactly
because it's a heart so a heart can
connect with a heart and so what Dr
Kareem did I'm jumping forward a few
levels here to explain biosignitions is
that he looked at it's not just the
outer shape although the outer shape is
very important
the boundary of anything contains
embedded information the shape of a
human body is important typical organ is
important
but what he then looked at is that that
shape of the heart that shape of the
liver that shape of the kidney
it actually then becomes a container
that has energy circulations inside of
it
and not just one energy circulation
there may be
nine or ten or a dozen different energy
circulations inside the heart every
energy circulation inside the heart is
creating a different
Consciousness energy physiological
function
there may be one related to the heart
beating there may be one to the heart
doing filtration of the blood there may
be another one or whatever the
physiological functions are but also
related to energy and Consciousness
that's why in some Sufi Traditions
they'll have you focus on a specific
point in the physical heart because it's
what connects the beat of the physical
heart to a higher Cosmic origin
that is what it's entrained to
and so with the biosignatures he then
began to use radiusthesia which is the
ability to detect and Trace out energy
movements of subtle energy
he then was able to trace out the way
energy moves in the human heart in a
whole variety of different ways it was
originally a three-dimensional energy
movement pattern that he then flattened
and simplified into a two-dimensional
image to become a bio signature but that
that says this two-dimensional
representation of a three-dimensional
energy flow in a particular part of the
human physical body or energy field
that's linked to a specific function so
in the biogeometry trainings when we
teach people the biosignatures
we show them how they work energetically
in the body and how you would test a
person for which ones they need because
what happens is those energy
circulations in the body can become
impaired they've become impaired through
trauma they become impaired through
physical illness they become impaired
through toxin build up any number of
things when that energy circulation of
the organ becomes impaired then the
function begins to degrade so what
you're doing when you provide a
biosignature to a person is you're
creating a resonance effect reminding
the body of the correct energy
circulation and then restoring the
function to it now we don't make any
medical claims for it but that's the
idea so like what Reiki what they do in
Reiki by being able to go into the
energy body and look at where the energy
is I'm very curious about the somatic
work has become more and more popular
right now where you're using sort of
your breath and you know your own
you're using your essentially a lot of
your breath and moving your body to find
and move stuck energy so can you explain
what stuck energy is
yes so for example if you were to go to
a Dallas Chi Kong healer from China
and you had a lung problem they may have
you make the same movement a thousand
times a day
because this is a movement of your body
following the the etheric energy flow
that's actually going to restore the
right circulation to the body and that's
what a lot of this Qigong type things
are oh my God yeah you're moving the
field right you're like moving the
energy
exactly and then oh my God so the
mistake that that they make teaching it
in the west is they try to teach it to
you like a dance yes
and then this is hard to remember it
because it's like let's go here next to
it but you're focused on the physical
body part instead if you had the person
focus on the energy movement and just
let your body be moved by the energy
movement then it has a completely
different impact and it makes a whole
lot more sense so like one of the basic
movements in XI Kong is like you let
your hands like moving through water
and so if you just say Okay move your
hands like this the energetic effect is
limited but if you tell a person feel a
rising current of energy coming up from
the ground that is lifting your hands up
and your hands and arms are completely
relaxed being pushed upward by the
column of energy that's what's really
happening
and so that's that's the concept behind
it it's the energy flow moving the body
it was the original concept then it
became a more focused on the physical
movement but still has an energetic
impact but it's not as powerful as
feeling the energy move the body
so what is the benefit when you say like
they might have you if you have some
something energetically that needs to be
moved they might tell you to do like a
certain motion to
align and coordinate that energy in a
more coherent balanced
slow flowing way so if you're just
letting your body move like I mean I
think about like there are you know
people that do incredible work with
getting people to move their bodies and
you know they're very they do more
intuitive kind of interpreted
interpretative dance and you know that
is so uncomfortable for a lot of people
I mean me as one like I mean I'll do it
but it's like you know I also I'm I'm
really good I like to execute so like
it's like what's the move again
um but to just kind of move like freely
without anything so what are you
actually doing if you're if you're if
you're following the energy instead of
leading the energy with a certain
movement that makes it all more coherent
well there could actually be either you
could be following a particular energy
movement that's present and letting your
body move with it or it could be that
you are almost magnetically creating the
energy movement with the movement of the
body the movement of the hands Etc
that's when you then get to all of these
energy healing systems like chronic
healing or things of this kind where you
learn how to project energy out of the
hands but again it's the energy movement
that's doing the work the body's just
following along but it's the movement of
energy that's creating the effect so for
example in Chinese medicine they
describe that the vast majority of the
psychological and physical illnesses we
have are simply due to blockages in the
body of energy because if the energy is
moving properly in all of its places all
circulating then
I hope it's automatic but as soon as
there's any blockage to the movement of
the energy then stagnation comes in they
talk about a whole series of different
stagnations blood stagnations food
stagnation limp stagnation there's a
variety of stagnations you can have in
your body that then lead to these
problems and that can happen either
through external trauma like physical
impacts or illnesses coming in or it can
be internal trauma like our our doing
what Wilhelm Wright called armoring when
we have traumatic events the part of us
that doesn't want to feel or remember
that traumatic event we hold it really
tight we don't remember it will hold the
temples really tight or we'll have
ocular armoring and hold the eyes really
tight
or if we don't want to say anything
about it we'll hold the jaw really tight
or the throat is constricted and if we
don't want to feel around the heart then
we have shallow breathing and
reconstrict the chest or things like
this that's really fundamental work that
Wilhelm Reich did to start the modern
mind-body therapy movement like a
hundred years ago so the whole thing
here is that we're then suppressing the
movement of energy because we're trying
to suppress the feeling of the trauma
and some degrees that's a coping
mechanism because we might be in a
situation that we're not able to cope
with it right now yeah now when you are
able to cope with it you need to let it
move you need to let it out
so by letting your body lead the way
you're starting to liberate that energy
and so when you're doing things like
authentic movements and spontaneous
movement part of it is loosening up all
the myofascial adhesions and stuff that
most of us have because we're just too
rigid all the time and that feels
fantastic but it can also be in deeper
levels of that work and we've already
got the physical body a little more
flowing then we can really allow
ourselves to unify with larger energetic
flows in an environment or that creates
certain functions so like many of the
different chi-com sets that you have
from China they create different
energetic functions in the energy body
and they they again they're part of the
activation process like we talked about
before that we had healing then we have
activation then we have stabilization
the actual then movement of the energy
activates something or in the case of
biosignatures it restores the correct
energy movement inside the system of the
body using the correct energy pattern of
that flow so what is disease then well
disease that becomes another larger
topic there's actually a section on that
in the Advanced Training of biogeometry
but in dealing with it in a very short
frame one aspect of this is that we have
lost the correct energy circulation that
created the function of that part of the
body to begin with and at a deeper
metaphysical level it means that we've
lost a resonance between the
health-giving source at a higher level
of what comes into the body we're no
longer connected to it or no longer
resonating with it we got to reconnect
with it it's like stop it's dormant and
so that's why this healing is very
important but again it's to become whole
again the energy circulations are back
we're reconnected to those larger
metaphysical levels well I mean why is
cardiac disease one of the biggest
killers in the west today Broken Hearts
exactly everybody's got a broken heart
everybody's got an armored heart but
they hold rigid and they I do a lot of
I've done a lot of body work with people
in a way that's like energetic body work
this was a natural thing for me and and
so what you find when you're palpating
around both the person's front Heart
Center and their back Heart Center where
the more subconscious stuff is is the
amount of rigidity people have there is
incredible
now let me just throw in something here
that might be of interest so in the
Chinese tradition they understand that
there's three major Elixir fields in the
body three major alchemical fields in
the body and so one is in the head they
call it the upper Elixir field or the
upper Don Tien
and that's where we work on our
Consciousness then there is the middle
Elixir field that's around our heart and
our lungs and that's related to our
feeling function okay and rhythmic
processes in life and then at the lower
abdomen is the lower dantian now the
only safe place to store energy like
Dynamic Life Energy in the body out of
these three is the lower dantean it's
not safe to store it in the head it's
not safe to store it in the heart
that'll create migraines that'll create
heart palpitations the only place to
store the really powerful energy in the
body is the lower abdomen
and that's like a battery in the body
that's where we had the navel right
everything we took in from the mother
came in through the navel and so the
lower abdomen all the metabolic
processes there all the Sexual Energy
generation that's all lower abdomen
Style
so one thing that you'll find just like
you find the armoring around the heart
is something that's really impactful for
a lot of people I've done a lot of work
with women on this is in the lower
abdomen you'll find that for a lot of
women
to protect themselves from too much
aggressive energy particularly for men
coming toward them sexually or other
grasping things toward them they armor
the lower abdomen to a degree that
they're not even aware of they don't
know how armored and rigid they're
holding the lower abdomen because it's
such an intrinsic state it may have
happened in childhood or it may have
happened around puberty when they
started to get attention but it's like
something that holds back the dynamic
pulsation of the life force in the
abdomen it can be true for men and women
but it's particularly significant for
women
well it's you can simply feel it you can
put your hands on the abdomen and feel
the rigidity okay that's there now what
a lot of women do subconsciously to
avoid that area of being stimulated is
that if you start to touch them in the
lower abdomen they'll say stop it
tickles but the tickle response is
defensive mechanism
and if you start to actually loosen up
all of the the fascial tissue and things
in the lower abdomen it has incredibly
powerful effects for the whole Energy
System and the psychology and for women
this is one of the most important things
they can do is open up the lower
abdominal energy soften it allow it to
pulsate again and then the amount of
dynamic energy generation in the female
body is incredible What's
um what's a practice because
maybe not everyone can do this I'm not
saying I'm the best but I can definitely
Energy's my field of information like
that's how I that's how I sense things I
sense coherence and frequency with
someone I have three EMF reducers in my
house I took the Wi-Fi out of my bedroom
like that's just something I'm sensitive
to yeah so if we were able to
energetically sort of tap into each
chakra what is and we can feel whether
or not it feels tight or whatever
information we're getting how can we
approach and maybe I'm not even
directing it towards the right places
but are you talking about the lower
abdomen and I start thinking about
sacral solar plexus all of the chakras
so and some people are very blocked in
their throat chakra so what if we went
through them is there something that we
can do to
um
loosen it
to get it to the flow so before I was
talking about the lower abdomen a lot of
this is like myofascial release a lot of
this is is like actual physical opening
up the
the ability of the flesh the muscle to
be soft and mobile and pulsating again
right but behind that again at the next
energy layer behind that then you've got
the chakras the meridians things like
that so what I would mention just very
briefly as one of the most important of
all exercises
because it allows you not only to open
up the energy in the center it also
allows you to become aware
of the actual spiritual power that's
held in any location in the body any
chakra in the acupuncture point is the
Basic Energy movement that I teach very
briefly in the uh Gaia series and I
teach in more detail in other courses
which is what I refer to as zero point
centering and Radiance so if you think
of a spear and the spear is losing air
and is collapsing into its own Center
becomes a point and it just the point
gets smaller and smaller it's going into
the center of the center of the center
constantly shrieking this is related to
the movement of the planes as well this
is explained very well in Egyptian
biogeometry but the basic idea is that
normally when we are
needing to understand the world around
us and navigate safely in a physical
world all of our attention from our
senses is going outward it's going
outward in a sphere of information
around the body to make sure I'm not hit
by a truck or whatever it is
but if you're going to become aware of
things in the inner landscape aware of
the spiritual reality the energetic
reality instead of the awareness going
outward
it needs to go inward
so for example you could put your
attention at the Arjuna Center which is
between the eyebrows slightly inside the
skull this is a particular system I
learned from Samuel Sagan at the Clear
Vision School in Australia but it's
really a universal pattern that is
understood by many traditions because
it's based on a sacred geometry
archetype
and that is you put your attention in
any energy center of the body we'll just
say ajna as an example okay but it could
be the lower abdomen it could be the
sacral Center sofixes whatever you put
your attention there and you go inside
as you move from the physical plane
awareness you then move into the
awareness of the vibrational state of
what we might call the etheric or the
chi or Ki or Prana that's the next level
beyond the physical the dynamic life
force and then your awareness body as
well the the Egyptians exactly they talk
about the car body the and the energetic
field around you that's exactly the car
body exactly and so all the Traditions
had a name for it yeah and so as you
move into it you are shifting your
awareness of it to to modality where the
etheric Shiki pranaka is experienced as
vibration or tingling or density or
pressure or hot and cold these are all
Sensations inside the energy body right
and so when you feel that again could be
at any energy center you then move all
of your energy and attention into the
center of the center of the center of
the center of what you feel
and as you do that you're actually
moving through the planes
now again this is best described in
Egyptian biogeometry which talks about
how the planes are assembled outside of
our body in a series of layers but also
inside of our body in a series of layers
so as you're going into the interior you
go from the physical awareness outward
to now going in at the vibrational you
feel the vibrational you go into the
center of the center of center of
whatever you feel because you don't want
to have it be an abstract thought form
out here you want to feel it in your
body that's the only way it's going to
work
and then when you go deeper into it you
then get to the astral layer that's the
first level of Consciousness now rather
than feeling the vibration density
pressure you become aware of light and
color that becomes the
the modality of the astral plane and
then you keep going into the center of
the center of the center
and what will happen is you go through
all the planes until you reach the
absolute Center which is the Divine
plane Divine plane is in the absolute
Center of everything
and so as you've moved all the energy
and tension into the center of the
center of the center of this place in
your energy body when you touch the
Divine plane it activates it when you've
moved into the absolute center with your
energy and attention it's like when you
Namaste recognize the Divine in the
other person and in your seeing the
Divine in the other person you're
actually activating it and so when you
move your attention tangibly into the
center of the center it builds up energy
you touch the Divine Center what happens
then is it activates it and now the
energy begins to flood outward and it
becomes a illuminated sphere of light
around the head so that's where you see
all these pictures and classical
Traditions about like an illuminated
spear around the head of the initiates
or they have a whole illuminated energy
field but they don't tell you how to
activate it right right they just like I
feel like in in history they would just
say it's like a crown yeah but they're
not telling you because they probably
didn't know what the actual initiation
practices were so this is one of the
most important practices of creation
everything came from the one from the
they say in physics is the singularity
right the singularity is an
infinitesimal point in space Zero
Dimensional and then that expanded
outward like in the Big Bang to create
the space-time enclosure of this world
that that we live in
but the the cosmological movement is
from that Center outward
and then back from the expanse back into
the center for like seven back around
again to one all right
yes the cycle will always repeat but
that's the whole thing this is love
right we're getting back to the one
freedom freedom love freedom
so I do have like a question because of
the you're such a your awareness for the
energy and what's really happening
so when I picture energy coming up my
spine and into my head into the pineal
gland I if I focus there it is like it
almost is like a headache it's like a it
feels like incredible heat yes and what
is happening so this is something very
important uh in the 1960s and 70s we had
a lot of Indian gurus coming to the
United States and teaching people things
like Kundalini meditations to blast the
Kundalini up the spine to the top of the
head but the problem with this is that
first of all the energy body isn't
cleansed enough like they were doing the
ashrams for decades then it can be
what's called a diverted rising and the
energy can go into a secondary Channel
which doesn't have the ability to hold
that level of voltage but the other
problem with it is that raising the
Kundalini all the way to the crown of
the head would be used by some other
Traditions like the Tibetans and the
Paul Wall practice as a method of
conscious death or excarnation you shoot
the pearl of your spiritual self out of
the head and it's a conscious form of
excarnation now because we're only given
fragments of information the day we
don't always know how all these
practices fit together
and so what can happen is that when we
get the spinal energy rising up
when we get activations of centers in
the head particularly the pineal
pituitary like I said it's not safe to
store the energy in the head it's not
safe to store the energy in the chest
it's only safe to store it in the lower
abdomen that's just the way the body is
designed the lower body the lower
abdomen is the battery it's the life
force enclosure in the body this is for
Consciousness this is for feeling the
life force vibration that's for the
lower abdomen but we're so neurotic
about the lower abdomen and sexual stuff
in our culture like I don't want to talk
about that but that's where the energy
needs to get stored and so in the 1980s
I mentioned before that the deeper
daoist work uh for an inner Alchemy
began to be released to the public for
the first time been very secret before
so one of the things that they did that
helped a lot of people with this problem
is they taught people the idea of the
microcosmic orbit so the microcosmic
orbit is that there is a channel of
energy running up your spine that in
Chinese medicine is called the do
Meridian or the gov burning vessel
there's another channel that runs up the
midline of the front of your body that's
called the conception vessel or the ren
Meridian
and the two of these are meant to link
together and then become a flow of
energy
now to do that you need to touch the tip
of the tongue to the roof of the mouth
because this Meridian coming up here
terminates at the tip of the tongue and
the tongues also acts like an electrical
conductor
that's why in Sex and things that that
the tongue is such a powerful stimulator
it has an electrical charge to it so
when you plug the tip of the tongue into
the roof of the mouth it then connects
to the energy coming up the spine coming
over the top of the head and then to the
upper palate that's where that
terminates in the upper palate of the
mouth touching the tip of the tongue to
the roof of the mouth now you're
connecting the front and the back
channels together and you let the energy
then run down the front Channel until it
begins to circulate up The Spine down
the front
now what this does is it allows you to
not build up the energy that is coming
from the spine to the head it's meant to
circulate if it gets jammed up up there
it leads to what's called a Kundalini
sickness where you have too much tension
and pressure in the head yeah it's meant
to be circulated so after you've
circulated up The Spine down the front
this is just a very simple explanation
of what can have other aspects to it is
you then when you're finishing that
practice is you start to make a Vortex
movement at a level below the navel in
the lower abdomen but an inch and a half
below the navel in the center of the
body okay and that's a place that when
you make a Vortex movement there you can
pull all that energy in and store it in
your internal battery where it's safe in
the lower abdomen so it comes up your
spine
into the to the tongue now the tongue
touches the roof of your mouth which
connects to the front energy channel so
then you send it back down into a Vortex
that essentially charges your body with
more energy that's right there's a type
of physiological energetic battery in
the lower abdomen and this provides it
can hold a lot of charge and then we do
that so you actually circulate it this
is a very quick explanation of a larger
process but you've circulated multiple
times up The Spine down the front so
that the whole flow is happening but
then if you want to end the practice by
making sure the energy is ending up
somewhere beneficial to create the
vortex to hold the energy in the lower
abdomen so it doesn't build up in the
head so it doesn't build up in the chest
because we need to open up the pineal
gland absolutely for higher
Consciousness we need to open up the
heart chakra absolutely for higher
Consciousness but again that's not a
place that we can store the dynamic
energy every one of these three Elixir
fields has its own function and once we
begin again see it in context when you
understand the bigger context everything
fits into place is this your explanation
you're so extremely articulate and so
intelligent that it's you know things
just land so well because you understand
it so well so thank you
um okay let's try and wrap up even
though you know I could absolutely go on
and on as you see my pure curiosity it's
just I've abandoned all my like notes
and stuff I'm this is just my pure
curiosity carrying on with what your
answers are what can people do to
explore
biogeometry at um an entry level or um
at a at a level that we can start
accessing and using so that we can
understand ourselves and and improve the
energetic structure of of our bodies and
how it all works and then also I'm
curious where to go next with the
rosicrucian order because I I know we
didn't talk about it a lot but but I I
find that very fascinating thing I find
the the lessons within it that you've
shared and that I've sort of touched in
other ways to be
um really powerful so let's be clear
most of what we talked about today is
along the lines of what I teach in
spiritual science or in vibrational
science okay and I have a series of
courses on my website
bessica.org and obesica with a V at the
beginning
b-e-s-i-c-a like investment Pisces
exactly it's where you get two opposite
polarities and the two circles they
perfectly overlap creating an
almond-shaped enclosure and again like
we talked about before that's where the
magic happened the two opposite
polarities where they overlap becomes
the portal in the center that's actually
in the iconography of of The Institute
with the vesica form so at vesica.org I
have the spiritual science and the
vibrational science courses related to
most of what we talked about here I also
am very fortunate to be able to teach
the biogeometry work developed by my
friend Dr Ibraham Karim from Cairo Egypt
and so we offered that the the other
courses I offer are all online courses
you just do them at your own time
there's not a live component they're
just there for your own study when you
have the time to do it
the spiritual science and the
vibrational science work spiritual
sciences that work more focused on
developing the Consciousness vibrational
science more in developing the energy
body okay and being able to work with
energies in and around us okay then the
biogeometry is Dr Kareem's work which is
teaching Nature's Own design language
which is how shape sound color motion
number angle proportion can create
specific energetics that we can use to
balance our homes our offices and at a
higher level within our own Energy
System and activate the Energy System
as well as balancing with biosignatures
and things like that so that's
also listed on our website vesica.org
and this class has a pre-recorded
components and a live component where
people will join us for three days on a
weekend in a row three weekends in a row
for one day each weekend and there's uh
four hours where we have practice
reviews of things I've taught them in
the class will give them a summary
they'll send them off to coaches to work
with to ask any questions they have Etc
so all this is available through my
website bessica.org as structured
courses that can be taken and asked
about the rosicrucians the Russo crucial
work is primarily in the spiritual
science side I always tell people to
start with essential teachings and
practices of spiritual science because
that gives you some of these
fundamentals I talked about like the
receptive and active meditation and
things like that but I also have a
course that's specifically about the
rosicrucian work
which is uh called the the true
rosicrucian tradition and it's got
multiple courses that go into a lot of
the deeper rosicrucian knowledge and
that's a one of my favorite topics so I
always love talking about that no okay I
mean I hope that I didn't use too much
of your time up for you to
um say no when I ask you to do this
again but I'd love to dive into that
another time because I I find I find
that work to be it's very magical
wonderful I would I would absolutely
love to talk with you again specifically
about the rules of trujian tradition
because it's really in a sense a modern
expression of the Egyptian and like a
modern cultural context it has so much
in it and uh I'd also love to talk to
you sometime about the biogeometry
because that's a huge Topic in itself
and it really makes it available to us
what was previously very hidden
knowledge and practices from the ancient
Egyptian temple science but in a modern
context where it's easier to understand
and apply sure sure absolutely I I was
totally on my list of questions was like
what about a house and like play lines
and energy grids and the the geometry
and like shape of the house and like
should I have a friend who does crystal
grids underneath houses and like
there's so many places to go which is
why I struggled so much with like where
to go with all of my uh with with the
interview today but it was so
enlightening and so fascinating and
hopefully it's got people uh it has
people inspired and motivated to dive
into more of your work and go to your
website and do the courses and I sure do
and you know be ready for the next
interview so thank you so much I really
appreciate it thank you thanks everybody
for listening to the pretty intense
podcast today I hope you enjoyed it if
you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
Subscribe button